como foi a primeira pessoa que viu o
gêmeo Quando nasceu falou eita tava
parindo saiu dois falou á meu Deus do
céu fá vixe vixe vixe vixe já isso como
é que gêmeo se xinga ele se xinga o
gêmeo idêntico ele se xinga porque é
igual sabe que se você se xingar você
xinga a ele também você chega para cara
falar assim rapaz mas eu sou feio viu a
o outro responde eu sou feio o quê eu
sou feio o quê ô meu Deus do céu agora
pronto ai tomar no meu cu ai tomar no
meu cu tu tu me calar essa tua boca vou
dar um tapa na minha cara por dar um
tapa usto tu forom é tu forom cara pega
no próprio cabelo dele e fal tu vem
agora a outro fala solta solta tu me
solta tu me solta solta sol tu me solta
vou enfiar o dedo no meu parou parou
parou é difícil ter irmão